[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hello
game developers,
and welcome to yet another
exciting episode of "Game On!"
I am Todd Kerpelman.
I'm a developer advocate here
on the Google Play Games Team.
And here with me
today is Wolff Dobson,
developer programs engineer,
also on the Play Games Team.
And he is here to talk about
one of my most favorite things
in the whole wide world and
that is physics engines.
So Wolff, why don't
you take it away?
WOLFF DOBSON: Alright.
So today we're going to
talk about Liquid Fun.
This is our brand new open
source physics engine that
we've just released
cross platform in C++.
TODD KERPELMAN: Very exciting.
WOLFF DOBSON: Mmhmm.
So first thing we should talk
about is, where do you get it?
And our producers
here have added a link
that you can click
on that'll take you
straight to our GitHub page.
And in this little chat here
we're going to do an overview.
We're going to do some
demos and we'll even
talk about a little code.
So, first, let's talk
about physics engines.
TODD KERPELMAN: What's
a physics engine Wolff?
WOLFF DOBSON: It's your
favorite thing in the world.
TODD KERPELMAN:
Oh, that's right.
WOLFF DOBSON: So,
a physics engine
is the mathematical
simulation that
helps you create procedural
animations filled
with physical bodies.
So in a game, you're
simulating per frame.
And the system divides times
into little slices and updates
on all the objects
each frame based
on their positions
and velocities.
So there are conflicts,
like collisions,
then the system
resolves those safely.
The most basic physics
simulation you can think of
is actually "Pong."
A single body,
it's moving around,
bouncing off
against two paddles.
TODD KERPELMAN: I
guess that's true.
WOLFF DOBSON: This is obviously
a little bit more complicated.
Liquid Fun, that
we're providing,
is just a numerical simulation.
We have a little simple
visualization, but in your game
you're going to want to add art,
and sound, and story, and all
the rest of that stuff.
This is just the
mathematical part.
TODD KERPELMAN: So like
in a model view controller
kind of analogy, this
would be the model.
This is telling you where
everything is in my game,
but it would be up to my game to
actually take that information
and turn that into
something on-screen
that I would present
to my player.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: Alright.
WOLFF DOBSON: So, this
is a superset of Box2D.
Box2D, I'm sure you've heard of.
TODD KERPELMAN: Box2D, yes.
It's a very popular 2D physics
engine developed by Erin Catto,
I believe, and it's used
in just about any game
out there that uses physics.
I know "Angry Birds" uses it.
WOLFF DOBSON: Anything with
2D physics has Box2D in it.
TODD KERPELMAN: There's
a pretty good chance
that it's using Box2D.
WOLFF DOBSON: If
your game uses Box2D,
you should be able to
drop this engine in
and it will just work.
So just as a view,
this is the typical--
this is our typical
[? system ?] demo here
that shows just rigid bodies
interacting with each other.
TODD KERPELMAN: This
is demonstrating
a lot of interesting
things, right.
It's sort of demonstrating
first, gravity,
and also momentum,
and I guess you'd
see angular momentum if that--
WOLFF DOBSON: Joints too
on the thing and motors
turning the thing.
But this is all very
standard Box2D stuff.
The sort of special sauce
we're adding with Liquid Fun
is, obviously, Particles.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oooh.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
So let's look at
some particle demos.
This is a whole
bunch of particles
and a giant rigid body slamming
into all those particles.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah,
that's a lot of particles.
That's thousands and thousands
of particles running around
inside there.
And this is an
active simulation.
So if I grab hold of this, I
can kind of swim through this
and push these guys
out of the way.
I can touch groups of particles
and throw them around.
It's pretty cool.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
Because normally when
I think of particles,
I think of them
used for, sort of,
visual only effects,
like fire and smoke.
But I guess what you're
saying is particles could also
be used for generating
things that look like water.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
And these particles
are actually--
and these particles can
interact with the entire rest
of your physical system.
This is your typical
wave machine.
You can actually
see wave physics
going back and forth
as it swims around.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
And so, basically this
engine is simulating
each of these thousands
of particles individually,
and sort of, by grouping all
these behaviors together,
you get something that
suddenly creates waves.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah,
it looks like water.
It's pretty neat.
TODD KERPELMAN:
Yeah, that's cool.
WOLFF DOBSON: So, as I
mentioned before, the engine is
cross platform.
It's written in C++.
And we provided builds out
of the box for Android NDK,
obviously.
We also have Linux,
OSX, Windows,
and people can feel
free to contribute
to whatever other
platforms they want to add.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
So there's a pretty good
chance I could add this
to any mobile game I wanted.
WOLFF DOBSON: Mmhmm.
TODD KERPELMAN: Alright.
WOLFF DOBSON: So, this is
kind of way out of scope,
but we'll talk a little bit
about how physics engines work.
So in a physics engine, you
basically create a world.
You add some rigid bodies to it.
So here, a circle
and a triangle.
You might add some
joints to connect them.
And then you step the
simulation forward.
In this case, since there's
nothing supporting those guys,
there's just going to fall.
But again, the secret
sauce with Liquid Fun
is that we're adding very
large numbers of particles that
can interact with
these rigid bodies.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
So what makes a particle
different than a rigid body?
WOLFF DOBSON: So particles are
the smallest unit of matter
that can interact with things.
They act like rigid bodies,
but they don't have rotation.
So we consider them
uniform circles.
And they are, sort of, packed
intelligently in the system
so that they can be rendered
and simulated very quickly.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: Rigid
bodies, basically,
are going to be
slow and expensive,
and particles are
small and cheap.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
So by basically placing a few
limitations on these things,
the engine is then
able to render
hundreds or thousands
of them at once.
WOLFF DOBSON:
Thousands, definitely.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: So
particles come with
basic physical characteristics
like color, size, position,
velocity.
Color is for your reference
when you're rendering them.
It doesn't actually
have any effect
on the numerical simulation.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
I can ping the model and
say, hey, what's this?
WOLFF DOBSON: What
color is this?
And then also, strength.
So if you have particles that
are sort of stuck together,
like viscous
particles, you can say
how strong you want
that viscosity to be.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: And
as noted, there's
no rotation for particles.
So if you rendered them
as little top hats,
the top hats would
always be facing up
even though
thousands of them are
smacking against each other.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
So as a general
rule, you probably
don't want to render
them as something
that-- where you would
notice it doesn't rotate.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: In
fact, most likely
I might apply some
sort of filter
to not show the individual
particles, but kind of group
them together so I might
see a big wave or something.
WOLFF DOBSON: No, actually,
in these simulations,
we're just sort of
rendering a gaussian spot.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: And
as lots of them
are-- as they sort of-- the
spot is a little bit bigger
than the body, and as
they overlap each other,
you get the sort of the areas
that look kind of solid.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: So here's the
code for creating a particle.
If you've used
Box2D before, this
should seem really familiar.
You create a particle Def.
You can set some flags on it.
And you can also set its
position and its velocity,
but not its rotation.
And then you tell
the world I'd like
to create a particle
using this definition.
TODD KERPELMAN: What does
elasticParticle there mean?
WOLFF DOBSON: So
elastic particles
are springy particles.
They're particles that
are connected together
like a jelly.
We'll see one in just a minute.
TODD KERPELMAN: Alright.
WOLFF DOBSON: We'll see a
lot of elastic particles
in just a minute.
A particle group is created by
instancing sets of particles
together in a shape.
They're ways for you to create
and destroy lots of particles
at the same time.
So you can set all
the regular properties
like velocity and position.
But you can also add
the rotational angle
if you have one
of these jellies.
You can also set-- sorry,
you can rotate the shape
and then you can set
the rotational velocity
as well if you have
one of these jellies.
TODD KERPELMAN: So particles
don't have rotation,
but a particle group
does have a rotation.
WOLFF DOBSON: If it's
an elastic one, yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
I think.
I think you're going to
need to show me a demo.
WOLFF DOBSON: I think
we're going to show a demo.
TODD KERPELMAN: Alright.
WOLFF DOBSON: So creating
particle groups is,
again, should feel pretty
familiar to Box2D people.
You create a shape, You create
a particle group definition
object, and then you
instance the group with that.
So--
TODD KERPELMAN: What
does the shape here mean?
WOLFF DOBSON: A shape
is a Box2D primitive.
So it's going to be a polygon.
So you can make a circle.
You can make a giant square.
You can make it L-shaped.
You can do whatever you want.
TODD KERPELMAN: And is the
idea these particles have
to fit into that shape?
WOLFF DOBSON: It
will create particles
with the density in the
shape that you specify.
TODD KERPELMAN: Hmmm-- OK.
I'm a little confused.
Maybe you can go
through this code
and let me know what you mean.
WOLFF DOBSON: Right.
So you can see here we
have the particle group
definition and a shape.
The shape is just a box.
And then on the particle
group definition we're saying,
look at this shape.
We're setting some flags
on it-- its initial angle,
its initial angular
velocity-- and that's
the angle of the entire
shape that we're setting.
And then we're instancing five
groups of these all at once.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
you're creating-- I see--
you're creating five groups of--
WOLFF DOBSON: Of square
shaped particles.
TODD KERPELMAN: But
then within these, you
do need to, then,
create the particles
that are attached
to these shapes?
WOLFF DOBSON: No.
When you say create particle
group, you just [whoomp],
you instance all of these
particles at the same time.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, OK.
And so that's where the
shape definition comes in,
is it's creating these
groups that-- these groups
of particles that
essentially fill this shape.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
And the density of
particles within that shape,
is that something
that I would specify?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, you
can set the particle size.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
So I don't need to
have four nested--
that create all
these thousands of particles.
WOLFF DOBSON: No, no, no, no.
You just make a shape and it
will fill it with particles.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well that
makes a whole lot more sense.
Alright.
WOLFF DOBSON: So if you want to
destroy particles as a group,
it's pretty easy.
This code example here
walks the entire list
of groups in the world and
just destroys all of them.
This would be like a
simulation shutdown step.
The particles in the groups
can interact with each other,
but then you can kill
the groups en masse.
TODD KERPELMAN: So let's
say I have two groups here,
and I mix them all together,
and they form this giant mess,
I could then say kill group A
and, like, half my water will
suddenly disappear.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: Huh.
So I guess you've got to
be careful about using
that to make sure that that's
actually the side effect
that you want.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: Once you start
pouring liquids together,
they become intermeshed.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: Particles have
a lot of different behaviors.
By default, they operate
as a simple liquid,
but you can add these new
particles, like elasticity,
with flags.
So let's share some demos here.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: So first
I'm going to show you
a set of particles
that are elastic.
So here you can see they're
kind of acting like jelly.
And if I grab any small
collection of particles
and move them, the whole
body moves at the same time.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
And I can see they're
trying to keep, sort of,
their original shape.
WOLFF DOBSON: But
they can still be
deformed if I drop
objects on them.
They're going to, sort
of, deform to accept that.
TODD KERPELMAN:
And so these were
created by particle groups.
WOLFF DOBSON: Mmhmm, yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: One has
the shape that's a circle,
the other has a shape
that's a rectangle.
You've given them elasticity--
WOLFF DOBSON: Right.
TODD KERPELMAN: --Which means
that they are springy and they
cannot be broken apart.
WOLFF DOBSON: Right.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
So that would be
useful for like,
if I wanted to create
bouncy balls or just fun
looking jelly types of things.
WOLFF DOBSON: Like this.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: Because
it's such a cool jelly.
TODD KERPELMAN: And somehow
it's important for my game
to make sure that this is still
one solid object, it doesn't
get broken apart.
WOLFF DOBSON: Right.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: So
here's an example
of particles that can color mix.
So this is a regular fluid,
but as the particles brush
against each other, it averages
their color as they rub.
So you can see the
red and green turned
into this yellow on the left.
And If I kind of
mix these-- woops,
I kind of spilled--
if I mix these,
I can kind of bring
the green into the blue
and get kind of a
uniform light blue.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
And so these colors
basically mix just
based on when they touch?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
I could-- let's say,
as a developer--
I could use this
if I wanted to measure some
hot water and some cold water
or something.
I would just sort
of ping the color
as a way to represent how
hot or cold these things are.
WOLFF DOBSON: Sure.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
And so, I noticed these
break apart very easily.
So these are not
elastic particles.
WOLFF DOBSON: No, no.
These are regular fluids.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: And lastly, here
are some viscous fluids flowing
through a maze, and then we
have a couple little pumps that
are moving it back and forth.
And you can see I'm
getting this sort of blob
down here in the lower left.
TODD KERPELMAN: Mmhmm.
WOLFF DOBSON: And, also, if
you look up at the right,
you can see I'm applying a
constant force to this pump,
and it can't compress
this viscous fluid enough,
so it bounces off of it.
TODD KERPELMAN: Sort of
like real water, I guess.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: Right.
WOLFF DOBSON: And then
down here at bottom-- oh,
there it fell by itself-- I can
use this to sort of pump water
uphill.
And knock this other
rigid body into the drain.
TODD KERPELMAN:
And so, by saying
these are viscous, what you're
basically saying is, like,
these have some amount
of surface tension?
WOLFF DOBSON: Mmhmm, yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WOLFF DOBSON: [INAUDIBLE]
want to stick together.
TODD KERPELMAN: This
gives me more realistic
looking water than
if they were not.
Like it would probably
look like sand
if you did not have this
viscosity turned on?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
It would look more-- it
wouldn't go here as much.
You would end up with as many
of these sort of big blobs.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
And the more and more
viscous, the more and more you
go from water to, like,
toothpaste or something.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: Alright.
Maybe maple syrup.
I'm trying to think of
fluids with high viscosity--
WOLFF DOBSON: Slime.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON:
Something like that.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: And we have
more particle behaviors
besides even these, like
powder, and tensile, and wall,
and things like that.
TODD KERPELMAN:
What do those mean?
What does powder mean?
WOLFF DOBSON: So powder would
be something like smoke.
It would be things-- it doesn't
stick to walls very well
and it doesn't want to stick
to itself very much at all.
So that's powder.
You can read more about all
of these in the user manual
that we have.
And speaking of our user manual,
come on by to our GitHub page.
Join us.
We have a discussion group.
And we have a
programmers manual,
and we have an API reference,
and have all the source
TODD KERPELMAN: Cool.
So what's the license on this?
You said it's open source?
WOLFF DOBSON: It's open source.
You can pull it into your game
right now, and publish it,
and that would be great.
TODD KERPELMAN: Awesome.
Well that sounds like
a very useful thing.
WOLFF DOBSON: Mmhmm.
TODD KERPELMAN: Why
are we giving this
to the world, Wolff?
WOLFF DOBSON: Because we
want to make games better.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh.
Well, that's a good idea.
WOLFF DOBSON: We want to
make people's games awesome.
TODD KERPELMAN: Alright, well
this seems like a good start.
As someone who is a big
fan of physics games,
I encourage you all
to take a look at this
and start adding crazy-looking
jelly things to your game.
There's probably a
whole world of water
and jelly games that we just--
WOLFF DOBSON: There's
a genre of jelly games.
TODD KERPELMAN: --just
waiting to be discovered.
And so maybe that will be you.
Yeah, seriously check it out.
I think physics engine I always
just find really interesting,
because it's like a very
complicated system where you
can have a lot of rich behavior
and create a lot of really
interesting, rich puzzles,
but at the same time,
a three-year-old
intuitively understands
how everything in the
world is going to react.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TODD KERPELMAN: So I think it
makes for a really good game
design.
That's, I think, why there's
so many good physics-based game
designs out there.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's really a
sandbox for emergent gameplay.
Unexpected things happen when
you put physics together,
and that makes it
surprising and fun.
TODD KERPELMAN: Or you could
really just make this wave
machine, and I'd watch
that for several hours.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah,
you get hooked just
looking at these things.
TODD KERPELMAN: So you said OSX.
Can I make a screensaver
using this stuff?
WOLFF DOBSON: If you want to.
TODD KERPELMAN: Awesome.
Alright, well I know what I'm
doing over the winter break.
Alright, well thank you
everyone for joining us.
Take a look at what we've
got at our GitHub page.
I think it'll be
pretty interesting.
And we will see you
all in a week or two.
Bye.
WOLFF DOBSON: Bye.